hello everyone i would like to welcome
you all for the very first session of
bioinformatics for precision medicine
program
this program is designed to introduce
students and researchers to the field of
bioinformatics applications in precision
medicine
in this program we will explore how the
various omics data types generated in
these studies can be analyzed and
integrated to study the basic biology
associated with viruses and their hosts
cancer onset and development and
outcomes this online program will
include weekly sessions with an
instructor online tracking and review of
students progress access to all
resources and materials online for
self-paced learning access to expert
guidance and problem solving education
and research pipelines and domain data
analysis on our big data server
in this session we will discuss about
overview of precision medicine program
current applications of bioinformatics
and precision medicine and much more
so to begin with what is precision
medicine
precision medicine is an emerging
approach for disease treatment and
prevention that takes into account
individual variability in genes
environment and lifestyle for each
person
this approach will allow doctors and
researchers to predict more accurately
which treatment and prevention strategy
for a particular disease will work in
which group of people
it is in contrast to a one-size-fits-all
approach in which disease treatment and
prevention strategies are developed for
the average person with less
consideration for the differences
between individuals
after decades of research we are poised
to enter a new era of medical practice
where detailed genetic and other
molecular information about a patient's
cancer is routinely used to deploy
effective patient specific remedies to
treat it
we are about to enter the era of
precision medicine where biology is now
seen as a field of data science biology
is rapidly acquiring the characters of
data science
billions of data on genes proteins and
other molecules are compiled in large
files and systematically studied
analyzing this data will lead to more
knowledge and understanding about living
organisms including human health
biotechnology crops and livestock
this program will give an overview of
bioinformatics for students biologists
and clinicians
the influx of data associated
methodologies and data-driven research
makes bioinformatics for life sciences
as prominent as the emergence of
computers for the tech industry
the goal of the omixlogic programs is to
provide training in bioinformatics
enabling independent research guided by
mentors and peer example
developing a growing community with
shared passion for data-driven research
and appreciation of citizen science
enabling students clinicians and faculty
of all backgrounds to develop novel and
independent research using latest
technology in life science and data
science
the omixlogic portal gives students
options for analyzing a given data set
code dependent paths or code independent
paths these datasets and associated
publications can be used in several ways
you can learn bioinformatics without any
coding at all
for that in each project may explain the
analysis pipelines on the user friendly
t-bio info platform for big data
analysis
you can also learn the scripts behind
many of the steps
learning to wrangle clean visualize and
analyze data in popular languages like r
and python in order to create your own
analysis
finally you can hear about the projects
and their research applications in our
mental guided programs where experts
share their experience and support
research projects developed by you
after using the t bioinfo platform to
visualize the pipelines and practice
analyzing
students are then able to take their
theoretical knowledge to remember and
understand levels of blooms and apply
that in a project
the apply analyze and evaluate level of
claims
then check their comprehension with
levels and badges certification of
completion and test
similarly faculty should be able to
assign the omixlogic portal to their
students with the understanding that it
will give them holistic and
comprehensive knowledge of
bioinformatics beginning with bytes and
molecules and on to designing their own
question-based project
after completing this course you will
know how to do the following
read and understand bioinformatics
literature perform basic ngs data
analysis processing steps
analyze data and form hypothesis prepare
data for machine learning drastic
signals with gene databases know what
type of data is required to answer
scientific questions create your own
bioinformatics analysis present your
results in an organized way all these
skills are essential in bioinformatics
and some can be translated to other
fields
so let's start up by signing up on the
learn.omicslogic portal this educational
portal will help you get started on your
bioinformatics journey
you just keep putting the link in the
chat box
if you have not yet signed up on the
omixlogic portal you can take this time
to create an account for yourself
our team is here if you face any of the
technical issues so we'll be here to
assist you with that
you can either create an account for
yourself by putting in the details that
that are required or simply sign in by
using any one of the social media
accounts that would include a google
account facebook
or apple id or orchid or twitter
thank you dr fatima
those who have already signed up can
maybe let us know in the chat box by
sending in a one or yes
and others can take this time to create
an account for themselves
meanwhile i'll go ahead so those who
have created their accounts already are
requested to complete their profile
a completed profile will have a profile
picture a full name with appropriate
capitalization
you should add the links to your social
media handles and also add a brief bio
about yourself that will consist of
educational background and research
interests
the mentors can view your progress under
the activity tab the courses you are
currently completing will appear under
the courses tab and finally after the
completion of your course the
certificates will appear under the
certificates tab
so for different parts of the session we
will leverage or mix logic resources
that you can use to learn about
precision medicine
asynchronous coursework with theoretical
material quizzes and practical
assignments a cloud-based analytical
server where you can analyze large
genomic data and visualize results the
omixologic code playground where you can
practice coding in r and python as well
as a repository of project examples
and these methods will include hands-on
exercises on the tbi info platform which
provides a simple and intuitive user
interface for processing and
analysis and machine learning methods
for multi-or mixed data
throughout the course the users will be
given the directions to access the tbio
info platform for processing and
analysis of rna-seq data
the platform includes demo pipelines as
well as data management and analysis
cloud infrastructure to run
bioinformatics pipelines
different stages of analysis are
performed in different sections of this
multi-omics platform
and behind many of these methods are
scripts which are written in popular
coding languages such as art and python
and these are also explained in the in
the tutorials that you will have the
access to as a part of this program
so from visualization of genomic data to
exploratory analysis and hand hypothesis
testing we have it all covered
after you register you will be
redirected to the courses tab here you
can search for any course title use the
tags to find series of resources around
the topic or choose one of the
collections down below here we will look
at the getting started collection
once you complete a course you will gain
500 points for running a pipeline you
will get 100 points and for updating
your profile you will get another 100
points finally participation and group
activities will give you 10 points and
after achieving the learning outcomes
you would have learned some of the major
best practices in the field of
bioinformatics you will be exposed to r
and python which are the two most
powerful programming languages
bioinformaticians will need to
understand how to use t-test regression
and other tests analyzing and managing
data in order to communicate important
information is another best practice in
bioinformatics
pipeline development and utilization is
another common practice
ultimately completing the precision
medicine program will help you enter the
field of bioinformatics since you will
learn several best practices